throughout the pandemic the island
continent of australia has earned a
reputation for imposing some of the
harshest and most sweeping restrictions
on travel
strict rules have applied to visitors
permanent residents and citizens alike
almost two years after closing the
country's borders prime minister scott
morrison announced a national security
committee cabinet decision to reopen
australia's doors
the condition is you must be double
vaccinated to come to australia
that's the rule everyone is expected to
abide by it
and it's very important that people
understand that requirement if they're
seeking to come to australia but if
you're double vaccinated we look forward
to welcoming you back to australia he
also made reference to serbian tennis
star novak djokovic deported and unable
to participate in the australian open
last month because he was not vaccinated
against coronavirus
but we just want to stress that you will
need to provide that proof of
vaccination
your visa is one thing but your entry
into australia requires you also to be
double vaccinated and i think events
earlier in the year should have sent a
very clear message i think to every
around the world that that is the
requirement to enter into australia
border restrictions were first relaxed
in november to welcome international
students and skilled migrants
the latest move is expected to
rehabilitate the country's beleaguered
tourism sector we need international
borders to open i think you know because
australia is a globalized country you
know you put the border to globalize the
economy you're done you smash you know
about time um it's exciting it's almost
like an end of a period of hermit
kingdomness endings i'm just really
excited i mean opportunities is what we
want opportunities to leave the country
and come back is great almost all the
part of the countries open their borders
but not australia but it so it was
really difficult and you know so many
people went to depression because they
had got a lot of plans
and so now i'm really happy that scott
morrison has made that announcement
today
visitors with valid proof of a medical
exemption for the vaccines are able to
apply for a travel exemption
but will still have to abide by strict
covet 19 rules that vary from place to
place including a two-week quarantine if
traveling to western australia the
country's largest state
zane basravi al jazeera